the vast majority of men today have at
some point in a marriage said happy wife
happy life or my better half right and
one of the things that you see when you
unplug from The Matrix and you start to
see the code as it drops in front of you
is a lot of your like people right now
listening to this I want you to take a
look around at everybody you know that's
married and then I want you to count on
you know your fingers and toes how many
of them are actually happy versus the
ones that are actually married like
clearly happy that I've been married for
a long time the other thing that I want
you to take into consideration is how
many times have you heard them say
things like happy wife happy life or
she's my better half one of the most odd
odd behaviors that I see a lot of is
around birthdays and anniversaries and
even Valentine's Day is on social media
especially Facebook because if you're
married you know you often tag your uh
wife or your husband it's you know uh
you know Richard Cooper married to
so-and-so sort of thing and it's tagged
there and you'll see like on a wedding
anniversary she's my better half she's
the best person ever my best friend blah
blah blah blah and there's a picture of
him there with his family and his kids
and it's like you know like the whole
Hallmark card and then you click hers
and you look at what she's doing on that
day and it's crickets and there's a
picture of her on the beach with her
girlfriends drinking wine in their
bikinis right and it's like really
really like do you not see what's going
on here my friend you're the one doing
all the work you're the glue that's
holding the marriage together and she's
showing herself off to the world in a
bikini drinking wine with her
girlfriends in Cancun for the girls
weekend
foreign
I totally agree and I think the the
problem here though once again I would
actually put that in the um
it's a
it's a lack of frame from the [__]
men like you know if people look like a
frame if he I mean that reminds me of
what you talked about in your book it
was the I think you called it the
process of betaization right
monetization through a thousand
concessions correct yeah that's it so so
that that's what happens to a lot of
these guys is that as you said they to
get married I I mean but this is this is
the same with all sorts of things I
think it's you know people who start a
business for example that think that you
know I'm going to start a business today
and tomorrow I'm going to drive a BMW
and then you know a year later they
realize it was [__] difficult it's
like you actually have to keep uh
progressing and actually keep building
it so for me the most successful
relationships or marriages that I've
seen have been ones where the man
actually
his frame increases in the process
um it doesn't decrease and but but as
you said that's that's super rare it's
it's it's difficult though because
everything that Society is doing and
saying all the names Hollywood does
inspires exactly the opposite like it's
very common today for women to say hey
um it's so-and-so's birthday in uh you
know may whatever so we're going to go
down to Cancun together for a girls
weekend and the vast majority of men
would say okay because they're
incompetent morons and and they think
that you know things should be equal for
men and women and men and women are the
same and like there's no need to set
boundaries you try that with a guy
that's Muslim and it like the question
wouldn't even come up like I can tell
you right now my girlfriend wouldn't
even ask me that question today she
wouldn't say so and so is having a
birthday we're going down a Cancun you
know so I'm gonna go she wouldn't even
broach the question should we just say
to her girlfriends you go and have fun
sort of thing that's what frame is right
that's what happened frame is in a
long-term relationship because if a
woman's in your frame and she loves you
and she cares for you and you the same
for her you're not going to expose that
relationship to risk right and if you
think going to Vegas for a girl's
weekend or down to Cancun for a weekend
hanging out with your girlfriends where
there's unlimited amounts of booze and
unlimited amount of dick around them
that good things are going to happen
only and they're going to be sitting
around talking and gaggling about loving
their husbands and their children you're
a [__] like you are a gullible [__]
essentially at the end of the day and
that's that's the vast majority of men
today right like they'll let things like
that happen and I get Flack for it I'll
get called names oh you're insecure you
know you're overbearing you're
misogynistic blah blah blah no that's
how that's the way things have always
been right men had responsibility to
their woman but they also had Authority
yeah I think we're on the same page
there I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out